we have some questions for you mal you
may have grown up a lot since going to
auradon and we know you'll make a great
Queen but you're so young how do you
know that you're ready to commit to
being the queen of auradon and the isle
are you going to have a long engagement
to Ben or is this wedding happening ASAP
we want answers
a lot of Disney characters are way
younger or way older than fans may think
you won't believe which Disney Princess
is actually the youngest keep watching
to find out how the real ages of Disney
characters change everything say you'll
marry me
I'm very sorry Gaston but I just don't
deserve you
mother Gothel the villain from tangled
is obsessed with staying young she
kidnaps Rapunzel so that she can
continue to use the Sun drops power
entangled Eugene says she watched over
the Sun Drop for hundreds of years early
estimates of her age were based on her
clothes which put her around five
hundred years old
but in Rapunzel's tangled adventure we
learned she was once a student of Lord
de manitous he lived thousands of years
ago so mother Gothel is at least a
couple thousand years old Alice Alice in
Wonderland is all about a curious little
girl who gets lost in a strange world
but you might not know just how little
she was according to the book that the
movie is based on Alice is only about
seven years old
why is she allowed to go off on her own
and why is the Queen of Hearts so
determined to behead a really young kid
that is so messed up Snow White
the original Disney Princess was younger
than most of her later counterparts Snow
White is only 14 years old this makes
the movie really dark first stepmother
tried to have her heart cut out ring
[Music]
then she goes and lives with a bunch of
grown up dwarves why does he let her
boss them around and say when they go to
bed to make matters worse prince
charming comes and breaks the spell he's
18 when she's only 14 yes
Wally Wally is easily the cutest robot
ever and the movie was such a touching
story
Wally's appeal is in how tiled like an
innocent is but he's actually 700 years
old he's progressed at a pretty slow
rate but then he meets Eve she's only a
few days old but she's more advanced
than him while he will need a software
upgrade if their relationship is going
to work the Beast in the original Beauty
and the Beast there's a huge problem
with the beasts story he's cursed for
being cruel he has to find true love
before his 21st birthday but then we
find out he's been cursed for 10 years
that means he was only 10 years old when
the Enchantress cast her spell
who curses a little kid just for being a
brat the live-action movie fix this
creepy Platteville and made the beasts
older Meredith the independent archery
loving princess from brave is just
sixteen years old
we know the movie takes place a long
time ago and things might have been
different but her mother is trying to
get Merida married off they're trying to
find a husband for her
no wonder Merida isn't interested in any
of these boys she's still just a
teenager
this makes us sympathize with her even
more Malin been in descendents 3 then
proposes to mal once they get married
mal will be the queen of auradon then
was already the king but he was still in
high school when he took over the throne
in the first movie and we don't know if
mal has even graduated when she decides
to get married who decided it was a good
idea to let teenagers rule a country
most kids that age have a hard time
picking a university bullwinkle whole
country is a huge lifelong commitment to
Baca
Stephanie bought out Star Wars we have
to talk about Chewbacca you might think
that Chewie and Han Solo are about the
same age they're besties after all but
Chewbacca is over 200 years old
wookies live a lot longer than humans
fans have pointed out that Chewie and
Hans relationship is like a man and his
dog but it turns out that the dog in
this metaphor is actually han Solo
Kida geta from Atlantis is the oldest
Disney Princess by a long shot
according to Disney kiddos over 8,000
years old now Pluto the ancient
philosopher said Atlantis sank 9,000
years before his time if that's true
then kid it would be over 10,000 years
old but other people say that if
Atlantis was real it collapsed about
3,000 years ago
either way kid I've seen many millennia
that is one big age difference between
her and Milo Pocahontas Disney took a
lot of liberties with the story of
Pocahontas first of all the real
Pocahontas never married John Smith and
the relationship between the Native
Americans and the settlers didn't end so
happily but one huge difference is that
Pocahontas was only 12 years old when
she saved John Smith's life can you
imagine how different the movie would
have been if they had made her the
correct age it would be really
inappropriate it definitely makes us
think about the story differently
thankfully does he made Pocahontas
around 21 in the movie which Disney
characters age shocked you the most
don't be shy let us know in the comments
thanks for watching be sure to give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things we'll catch
you next time
you